you're gonna push me you slap out that
fat [ __ ] home you take this and pull
the style or you tell you to kiss me
you're right
lizard face to Eve
[Music]
hell yeah it was a greatest video
submission of all time shoutout to that
dude wowee I think we yeah I Solis LAN
from that guy I think you ought I got
money from back to the day outside my
old deal you turned a new leaf now Oh
get your drugs out of his face bro yeah
he had that hog on him boy you see that
fork sausage that wouldn't turn bro for
you bro that's that farmer John ham dude
this one's easy for me I don't like the
urinals like I was just at the mall I
like the urinals because you can see
everyone's [ __ ] up - you know I'm saying
you can peep and see everyone's dick I
think I liked a little bit of privacy
and we've talked about this before if
you look at other parts of people's
bodies you don't see their dick you know
like if you look at somebody's eyes or
you know their face or chin shoulders
legs feet hands elbows yeah my steps
back small the back row teeth there's
way more places to look so if you're
looking at people's dicks you're gonna
see them but you can't make eye contact
bro yeah you shouldn't be because you're
all peeing together yeah but yes
straight forward like a goddamn psycho I
like to see what's going on I'm also I'm
I think it's the movie True Lies like
two bad guys and come behind me so I'm
looking at the reflection in the little
metal part coming off I'm worried
someone's gonna attack so what I like to
do I like to go in the in the in the
with the privacy one I like to just show
them I got that super soaker I [ __ ]
pump into that thing gets really fast
and hard hard like a super soaker I want
everyone to know I'm bringing that
[ __ ] or not though I hate the guy
that does that he goes in there any
pieces fast and as hard as you can have
or smear oh and do you take your time oh
dude I will piss for two and a half
minutes brother I'll make a plant in the
hallway jealous brother
[Laughter]
you're like who is that guy you know
give that guy a hydration system is he
on road I go yeah through filtered I
heard one guy say man is that filtered
beautiful few t3g one I'll say this AB
urinal
no thank you okay first of all it's like
a gangbang at it on a drain it's like
all can this drain yes it's a lot and
then there's always that [ __ ] who
writes on the wall yeah like with the
phone numbers there's graffiti on the
wall there's always something nasty on
there but I like to go in and out bro
cuz you want to be there for too long
cuz homeboy next she's [ __ ] dropping
Osama bin
really get out bro
yeah yeah I mean I don't mind being in a
bathroom for a long time so I guess you
have to be you know we're kind of from
different sides of the track when it
comes din there I got a question for
Brendan when you're peeing in the stall
are you lifting up the toilet seat or
are you leaving piss on the seat next
person to sit down in because I've
rousted two people and they're all
building for doing that dude case by
case case by case if I'm at if I'm at
the gas station get the [ __ ] out of my
face write it down man if it's at a nice
place like I'm at the Grove or something
I know it's a nice bathroom some dudes
been holding that [ __ ] in all day and
he's after me I'll lift that seat
case-by-case yeah that's a good call
I'll respect the case-by-case on the on
the toilet seat now I had an issue one
time I was trying to get um a little bit
of gas and they and so I went into the
urinal and was one of those you know
that a couple urinals in there you know
it's like a family style and in the
bathroom I mean and while I was in there
some nutcase came in there you know some
deviant and it was a hitchhiker I think
or some guy that just you know wasn't
going you know didn't care where he was
going standard yeah he came in there got
feces out of his body right rubs it on
the door in everywhere loss to get out
so now I'm trapped into this [ __ ]
doodoo spackled us into the room right
Wow so now [ __ ] gingerbread yeah yeah
yeah talked into the room bro they had
to bust out the window and get us out
through there oh yeah this yeah Rama oh
man it was just ah [ __ ] VIPRE dis attack
[ __ ] vibrant it's case by case room so
it's case by case but look I'm not
afraid to be at a urinal if some of the
guys there are nice guys I don't like
pissing around mean geezer or if they're
bugging me the other thing too about
that privacy of the the big bowl
sometimes you want to play a game some
will come in there horrible diarrhea and
spray the sides and then you can knock
that down with your pH get down I caught
it's like it's kinda like an art or a
video game spaceship with your piss do
everyone is looking so weird
or not you know what journals I will
never well look I cannot believe I'm
talking to a man who urinates on top of
other dudes Dookie dude sometimes that
happens this case my face bro you
haven't been on the road enough then
you're in a road die half bro it
happened I pissed on a lot of things in
my life okay a BIST indoors outdoors
upstairs off buildings moving vehicles
dude I pissed I try to pissed on myself
in a jet once sure but I've never
urinated on top of another man see then
you ain't livin brother and I else we
got I'm glad to be ready for Theo's
bitterly important it's Jay rock yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
but I'm not sure which was better to use
tail or tissue you know I just can't
decide this guy's great I'll let you
boys write the guy's [ __ ] awesome
made my week that's j-rod I love that
dude that's talented I'm super talented
I think he's we're gonna avatar to so
this is an easy one for me all right
here's your throw a curveball
let's see how or tissue neither sock I
grabbed that old sock that old Nike sock
maybe doesn't fit in with the rest of
them I grabbed that I put my hand like a
hand puppet so it doesn't get any on my
hand and then I go I do that
snaky sneaking along my body what do you
use
what are you whatever you were just
doing please children's blanket first
illusions party supplies yes I don't
come anymore bro
so if I'm looking up with a girl or
anything even I don't come I just stop
before I'm gonna come and I just go home
is that what your Pio tells you do huh
no your Pio so sound a parole officer
you can't bust nuts your Pio doesn't let
you Belle's nuts I'm not busting a
frickin nut over for it something for
some girl that barely even know dude
what about it off the internet what
about dudes
um no also so I would say this towel or
tissue first of all a sock is just a
towel shaped like a foot you [ __ ]
ma'am almost you realize that yeah but
you can put it on ma'am let him put it
on your hand and then just [ __ ] it's
like a talking puppet that cleaned it up
and then when you're you up it to clean
up there see brother but also as a kid
your parents like that's just a sock on
the floor super crispy price sweating
and everything but if you have a towel
they know what's a baby they know what's
up using a ton of tissues they know
what's up sock they don't know what the
[ __ ] happening and you got to mix it
up maybe it's both socks don't use black
socks has to be white socks here dude
you don't know [ __ ] bro you don't know
[ __ ] you just come down the walls at
your house
Oh your mom thought it was candles dude
but now that you bring out candles I
will say this a lot of guys have a
camera by the bed will skeet out into
that candle dude you know what the best
thing is you're the best idea you've
ever come up with busting those lava
lamps yeah [ __ ] a sock [ __ ] towel
jackoff in the lava lamp yet now you got
entertainment why don't we make those
yeah see monkey lava lamp yeah yeah see
monkey semen key semen monkeys we got to
work on the title see more there yeah
reach halfway there dude I think you
know that yeah I think Robin nut lamp no
nope and then we're gonna keep thinking
about the title but uh but the thing is
I made my week though Oh
j-roc but I know this definitely not
tissues don't be an [ __ ] save the
environment man a towel you can reuse
can wash you know
yeah washing kills the environment
though no the environments gonna die so
that's why we gotta mark do our best
you know that's my homeboy wants to go
to Mars yeah full circle look full
circle yeah go to Mars we're gonna die
immediately dude stay here you might die
I'm just gonna go with homeboy in the
truck and jacked off in the towels dude
look I I used to do the thing sometimes
I'd even put out like a beach towel a
nice big beach talent jerk-off on to
that or like I don't like having to
clean it all up so my thing you ever
jacked off in a hotel and just roll in
the sheets no me neither
never done that me neither ever and I
don't even like jerking off anymore man
so I'm trying not to do it your Bo says
no to that yeah well yeah I'm down like
I mean actually you're tough semi
recently but not that recently but
anyhow towel man I can't believe and
keep my eyes open towel let's go tell
them to get the other part Wow um what
happen has yeah oh shoot tissues goddamn
who's using Kleenex like a psycho yeah
somebody's doing paper mache God who is
it maybe that's what they're doing with
Boston in it and then making like
figures out of it oh I could see that
yeah me sense it is crazy how much semen
goes to waste every day in America when
you think about think about how many
loads are dropped right now
[Music]
[Laughter]
shout-out to j-rock gave Ron obviously
using all of the equipment at San
Quentin State Penitentiary I appreciate
it
and I respect that a hundred percent man
you're my real deal and this is a great
question
sex robot King immersed Ingham Brendon
I'm gonna go ahead and King them because
to get good at anything you gotta
practice since 10,000 hours to get good
at some think you think if you were a
kid think if you're nine you just got
that sex robot in your basement yeah
instead of jacking off into socks and
cushions and [ __ ] stuffed toys you
got this real woman you just pound townn
in it you know learning learning making
mistakes but learning learners are
phoning up to my time you're 18 you're
[ __ ] mandingo you're [ __ ] the
Wayne Gretzky of dick and [ __ ] down
oh dude you just it's an educational you
yeah you're freaking just John Stockton
just just dick it just process the time
yeah and by Dobbs I mean blow behind the
back yeah imagine be able to come behind
your own back and that's the matrix yeah
yeah that's the kind of stuff you can
expect out of have any sex robots you
know but I'm gonna say sting it because
human thing with sex robot either well
first of all sometime you know you go on
vacation you leave the batteries in
there the batteries leak out you got
acid leaking out the back you stay then
you got a dirty sex robot I think you've
got to take that [ __ ] in at a shop you
know or that man [ __ ]
and also how about this they're gonna
want to robots dude they're gonna want
yeah it's sex for like the first couple
months then they're gonna want to cuddle
then they're gonna want to drive your
car to get your wallet well click off
you don't think they're gonna learn if
they're learning out a [ __ ] and do all
of these down where Daniels in all of
these different positions they're gonna
know how to [ __ ] keep their own
switch on you don't think what our
[ __ ] is gonna reach back there and
fake
their own switch you think yeah dude if
they can give a [ __ ] they can [ __ ]
flick a switch dad dude I didn't think
of it you're talking about terminator
but they're [ __ ] us
yeah well they're [ __ ] us for like a
week and then and they're stealing our
cars dudes buying [ __ ] with our credit
cards imagine that doing our friends
[ __ ] each other Wow and we just have
to watch it's The Terminator but it's
exactly the Terminator I'm still into it
cuz I think you'd be a looot learning
tool I think the best of robots I put I
think the glass is half-full
I think if you have a robot you can dump
in their mouth then when you're 18
you're me all good
I bet rape goes down I bet everything
goes down you can take it out on the
robot
those things are powerful you can hate
[ __ ] a robot you get every Friday night
instead playing video games you and your
friend can run a train on a new sex
robot think about the possibilities dude
that's just you your buddy like being
gay but not one to admit it really I
think y'all are just [ __ ] up if
there's a sex robot there why your home
machine bro name's Tiffany my bad if you
got that Tiffany 3000 you know yeah but
what if you got that Donna 200 and it's
a little [ __ ] sharp in there she's
older and she talks back yes it was like
wine oh she has recipes she rattles off
a tooth that's it and what if you just
get a refurb of like one who was like
yeah like maybe it's a robot that used
to work at be like a you know a
mannequin and like a um The Container
Store but now they refurbed it and got
it doing sex you know and it's just like
stiff and Jen yeah yeah yeah oh right
there who wants who want we got a sale
on know it's like the navigation it's
like a navigation on your iPhone you can
change the language that's a gallon a
gallon Jeff you know fill it yeah sail
in the stool section you know I'm like
what the [ __ ] is going on here there's
we're gonna have some hiccups we could
also hopefully download like Debbie from
the Bronx oh yeah she's just get us fun
hit that [ __ ] oh yes [ __ ] it [ __ ] it I
think your mom's gonna get pacing around
here my quitting the hell is gonna turn
it down turn it down busting these jaws
so I can use for cooking Oh boss I need
icing for Cinnabon language though bro
you're disgusting look j-rod it
definitely seems you need a sex robot
though based on this guy student has all
the sex robots bro this guy personal
dress is just like you and every episode
do you notice that yeah I love him my
brother yeah
he is my ears a robot yeah definitely
baking it kids can learn from it and can
scan you can decide what language to go
with and just bust nuts and not hurt
anybody care yet okay and I'm gonna go
sting because I think that hey um the
sex robots it starts off with sex and it
ends up with other stuff pay my car
insurance robot you know move out of the
house robot you know yeah it starts with
sex but it just it devolves into some
really time about the plot of the
Terminator yeah thanks bro come up with
your original ideas
that's the termination yeah I am I'm
talking about the plot of the Terminator
is becoming your life art imitates life
brother amount
[Music]
69 your clone for mentally Wow you would
do it you would definitely do it no you
it would definitely do it
you know both you have low sex drive so
I feel like you and your partner just
fall asleep you just talk about nap
sleep do we get a couple hundred bucks
for just discussing it and lay in there
next to each other I confused though to
who gets the million dollars me to the
clone he's still living do we split it
cuz that's only 500k I think sucking
dick for 500k a mil okay so and he's
awesome but do you have to put body in
your own mouth and you're not
controlling it bro that's crazy
you know well you know what you but you
know yourself like he's not gonna freak
out you know you know what's going on
you don't know what your clones doing
what if he's doing cloned oh poor
[ __ ] clone code bro yeah that's a
good point maybe dive into the same
stuff yeah bro that's crazy
you have to go to his place we have to
come to your place oh there's sudoeste
to me variable I probably I wouldn't
give me a hard pass for me really yeah
I'm gonna say sting that mil now I'm
gonna say sting and I'm all set bro
really yeah so you got to hook up with
your clone 69 and is your Colombian out
of actual human cells or is it like more
like plastic you think or fiberglass
like one of those vegan burgers is there
but also can the is the clone like is it
a transgender version of me or is it
just it's just like me
it's a [ __ ] boy he's the - [ __ ] boys
girl you're a [ __ ] or we bout to be
some [ __ ] boys or is it a transgender
be shop yeah like a like a like a
[ __ ] Bruce Jenner style you know I'm
saying you're looking a guy who only
delivers boxes to Claire's boutique dude
that's the [ __ ] you look like and also
would you do it huh would you do it
there's so much going on there me you
would really have an opportunity to get
to know yourself do you get to ask your
clone any question no man you just hit
it and quit it and he's on his [ __ ]
way with 500k he's like later nerd and
where's he taking it now future clone
maybe he's not sober he's gonna spend on
[ __ ] [ __ ] and drugs yeah I guess I
would do it just because I would want to
be you know try to help my clone out if
he's going through a tough time you
might need the money talking right yeah
I can't get damn he gave me an easy on
that I joking well no you got me on the
help of the mouth
what's my clothes like down and out bro
you think I really need this my life
suck your dick yeah well blowing himself
ain't gonna help him dude I sting it no
King